I believe today is a vindication for the
rights of immigrants that today we have
to reflect all of us on how we talked
about this case in the beginning and how
this swarm of reflection and reaction on
the base of what I believe to be the
racial dynamics of this case nothing
about mr. Garcia's arretez ethnicity
nothing about his immigration status
nothing about the fact that he is born
in Mexico had any relevance as to what
happened on July 1st 2015
oh yeah I can't even believe those words
were said by that man it is it is
breathtaking I know almost every level
and almost wrong on every level joining
us now for reaction to try this sort all
this out is Michael wilds who's an
immigration attorney in New York City
and in San Francisco Harmeet Dillon an
attorney a Republican strategist she
focuses on a lot of civil rights cases
she's a litigator
Harmeet let's start with you when this
game across my phone tonight I actually
got choked up I got choked up for the
signle family and for every American
family who's been brutalized at the
hands of criminals who should have never
been in this country in the first place
your take absolutely Laura I mean as a
citizen of San Francisco I was
tremendously disappointed not to say
ashamed of my city and that jury today
and the verdict that they gave you heard
the political rhetoric coming out of the
attorney there Matt Gonzalez's mouth and
despicably conflating this criminal
illegal alien who is several times been
deported from this country with
law-abiding immigrants like myself and
other citizens of this city and as if we
have no rights at all and this is really
an example of the city of San
Francisco's rolling out the red carpet
for illegal aliens and this is the
logical net result of that Michael I
want to go to you on this he said this
verdict has a lot of relevance it
vindicates the rights essentially of the
undocumented so is the message today if
you're an undocumented immigrant you are
deported five times you can come into
the United States shoot someone
get off on all murder charges is that is
that part of the message today cuz
that's what happened no sadly Laura I
joined you and everybody this evening
for the said lost for the Steinle family
and what looks like justice not being
served I happen to be a former mayor and
a former federal prosecutor myself and
there are multiple truths and theaters
that happen here this sadly although a
terrible event is an isolated event and
a pure result of a poor prosecution by a
state court prosecutor who did not
succeed in bringing home a guilty
verdict the prosecution didn't succeed
in it just like immigration didn't
succeed in stopping this man here but
for Isis poor presence on the border or
poor ability to do this this young lady
would have been alive and today we
cannot scapegoat immigrants or
immigration or refer to these
individuals all by one big save as
people that would cause Americans harm
let's not forget unless you're an
American Indian we all hail from
immigrants Michael don't spare me
Michael a very very talented lawyer I
was one in my day but for you to kind of
spout out the cliches about we're a
nation of immigrants we have a dead 31
year old girl right here and we had an
illegal immigrant hold on who's Sam
who's San Francisco refused to hold on
an immigration detainer in sheer
defiance of federal law federal law
which is supreme over state law when
immigration is rage to all Americans
they did not hold him they should have
held him he when he was removed from the
country you bet he shouldn't have come
into this country who stand up for stand
up for these criminals when Americans
are being brutalized in immigrants who
are legally here are being brutalized
make it frankly makes me sick to my
stomach I mean when Michael you respond
yet or may respond then you go I'm in no
mood for the cliches tonight I got
so Garcia Zarate pulled the trigger but
let's be clear blood is on the hands of
the politicians in San Francisco who
have made the sanctuary city policy the
law and kept all of us unsafe for a long
time
and also the on the hands of the Obama
administration which did not enforce our
borders for eight years and one of the
reasons that President Trump was elected
into office was his promises to seal
that border and keep us safe and frankly
now our entire state of California
thanks to our governor signing the bill
earlier this summer is a sanctuary state
so every citizen in California can look
forward to this type of situation
occurring if we don't protect our
borders it's really past time for us to
do that in this cycle moment and Laura I
resent the insinuation that I'm a cliche
kind of lawyer I was a federal
prosecutor and I share the loss of this
family the bottom line here is ice has
laws on the books and should have done a
better job at stopping this and until
they stop this properly we can't engage
in the political diatribe in the courts
the courts forensic Lee found that he
had caused an accident it was not
something he intended on doing he should
never have been here and this young lady
who had been alive had I stopped her and
it stopped him and you want to know
something there are so many ways whether
it's the building of a proper wall or
the enforcement of the laws on the books
that we can stop the federal felons and
criminals from re-entering mind you this
man can now be prosecuted federally for
reentering the United States after he
serves a time for the illegal weapons
charge but let's not much not escape
going immigration or make this father
think that but for all the people that
have accents in this country his
daughter would have been alone first of
all who's saying that except you tonight
no you just said cliche you accuse your
cliche your cliche is trying to rope in
you're trying to conflate legal
immigration and immigrant in immigration
the bifurcation of our system because
you say no no I know no you can't what
I'm speaking actually that's the way the
show goes so when you keep saying you're
scapegoating immigrants no we're not
what we're saying is he should not
been here you bet he should read here
don't take the blame all of the blame
and put it just on the feds when the
feds had a detainer out on him and San
Francisco did not know so let me finish
my sentence the feds have a detainer on
him and it's up to the feds to use their
due process yes that is not a dirty word
to go out and find this gentleman and
hey they're expecting the local police
who are overwhelmed with their own jobs
to then hand somebody over like this all
over again and frankly they're being
victimized and hearing these types of so
let's see the legal system and forget
due process and just pull this guy by
his ear and have him out because he may
kill somebody this is a joke what
happened in San Francisco is the murder
Julie let this guy out they let this guy
out like they let people out every
single day residents of San Francisco he
was hanging out for two and a half
months waiting a ticking time bomb for
this crime to occur he will now serve
under our separate the California laws
maybe two or three years for this crime
and then guess what
catch and release again thank you
California we are Michael you made some
good points I gotta say you made some
good points in the show but this is not
about legal immigration this is about
illegal immigration period